hey it's Justine and one guess where I'm
at if you guess copertino for the iPhone
event you would be 100% correct and boy
was this an event now obviously we knew
that there was going to be new iPhones
there are so many rumors about things
that were going to be out so we have an
allnew lineup of iPhone 15 iPhone 15 Pro
new Apple watch series 9 and also an
Apple Watch Ultra Series 2 and a little
surprise bonus we have airpods that now
have USBC charging another huge update
is Apple's 2030 plan which aims to make
the entire company carbon neutral by
2030 these Apple events are always so
much fun I love getting a chance to see
all of my tech friends and creators and
reporters from all around the world so a
huge thank you to everyone who says hi I
love seeing all of you and of course I
got to see my friend Tim Cook I also had
my aistin pink USBC cables because now
that the iPhone is USBC it is time to
celebrate good times so good to see you
congratulations you going to get the
pink phone oh look I'm so ready for the
thing like you don't even know okay so I
have a present for you okay so this is
is very fitting for the event I actually
was so nervous cuz I was like okay do I
give Tim one of my USBC cables s do I do
I not it's the pink iustin USBC love it
so we are so ready for USBC of course we
got our annual selfie it's always so
great to see him and the rest of the
Apple team they really do such an
amazing job putting on such a great
event all right let's get into it the
Apple watch has such a special place in
my heart it is one of my favorite Apple
products of course you know other than
the iPhone and the MacBook but the
series 9 now comes in pink it has a
bunch of new features like the new S9
chip which has a four cord neural engine
and is 30% faster it has improved Ultra
wideband capabilities to make Precision
finding and seral requests way better
this is also pretty cool you can now
access your health data using Siri it
now supports name drop and it has an
even brighter display that goes up to
2,000 nits but of course like I said one
of the most important things is it comes
in pink one of the new Apple watch
features that they announced is this
double tap feature which allows you to
actually interact without having to
touch your Apple watch so you just lift
your watch just like so you double tap
your thumb and index finger to perform
the actions on the watch basically this
will activate the main button in
whatever app you're in and if you're on
the home screen it will bring up your
recent apps and you can scroll through
them just by double tapping all right
we're testing out the double tap here so
I'm going to double tap to accept the
phone
call and now Apple has just called me
what a dream can I hang up on
them I did how about that and why I
thought this was really interesting is
this this is the action that you take
when you're in apple Vision Pro to
select things you use your eyes to look
around to navigate and then you simply
tap to select so I feel like this is not
only a really great accessibility
feature in the new Apple watch but it's
also a little nod to our future with new
Apple watches means new Apple watch
bands and I love accessorizing my Apple
watches they are now completely doing
away with all leather products leather
cases leather bands they've come out
with this new texture called Fine woven
and I got a chance to touch one of the
cases and it has this weird not like
plasticky but it's like more of a silky
kind of feel and it was pretty awesome
I'm definitely excited to check those
out they've got some all new AES bands
I've actually never owned one of the
Ares bands so maybe this year is the
year these Nike watch bands also are
really cool I love these Little Speckled
flakes in there these are also made from
old recycled Apple watch bands so it's
really cool to see them reusing excess
to make something new we also got an
update to the app watch Ultra 2 I was
really hoping for a matte black titanium
color we didn't get that but we did get
a much brighter screen up to 3,000 nits
there's some other great updates for the
ultra including a new modular Ultra
watch face there's updated ambient light
sensor for night mode and now you can
connect third party Bluetooth devices to
the Apple watch for cycling this is
pretty cool because a lot of people use
different devices to track specific
Fitness metrics and this will make
things like that so much more seamless
even with these new features the Apple
watch Ultra 2 battery life still has 36
hours of typical usage and 72 hours in
low power mode and as you guys know I
recently started diving because of the
Apple watch Ultra so you better believe
that I will be taking this diving as
soon as I get my hands on one and of
course the reason that we're all here
the iPhone 15 and the 15 Pros first of
all all of the new iPhones have this
brand new design with these awesome
contoured edges the first thing that I
Noti is how nice it actually feels in
your hand and how light they are the
iPhone 15 has this durable color infused
glass and aluminum design while the 15
pro has an incredible brush titanium
shell and of course as we all expected
USBC has now finally come to the iPhone
so we're bringing USBC to iPhone
15 when they announced this in the event
everyone was clapping and cheering I
mean we knew it was happening but until
Apple says it we just didn't know the
iPhone 15 is equipped with Apple's new
a16 bionic chip which will obviously
make for some big improvements in
performance it now has Dynamic Island so
now everyone can enjoy that little black
pill shaped Island up there at the top
of their screen it also has a new 48
megapixel camera that lets you take
super high resolution photos and an
improved 2x telephoto lens portrait mode
also got an upgrade you can now change
the subject focus in a photo after
you've taken it it's pretty magical
because you can just take a photo you
don't have to be specifically in
portrait mode to really take advantage
of these new features so this is
something that I'm really excited to
test out and now for the big boys we've
got the iPhone 15 Pro and the pro Max
one of the coolest thing about these new
pro version iPhones is titanium shell
and when I say these things look really
beautiful in person there's just
something so immaculate about the
titanium look of course I was hoping for
some more elaborate colors for the Pro
Series there was even rumored at one
point to have a red phone what happened
to that nobody knows but I'm glad that
they went with these more kind of Earth
Tone natural colors even this blue
titanium is so pretty so with this new
titanium shell the strength to weight
ratio of this new material means this
phone is going to be Apple's strongest
and lightest pro model model yet and I
can definitely tell when I first picked
up both the pro and the pro Max they
felt so light now it's not like our
iPhones are very heavy but it is
something that I have and I hold every
single day probably I mean I don't even
know how many hours a day I have my
phone in my hand it's more like how many
hours in the day do I not have the phone
in my hand but immediately I notice a
difference and I also just love the feel
of the titanium finish like it just
feels so fresh this is also some pretty
big news there is now an action button
so they repl placed the little silent
toggle switch to mute and unmute your
phone I pretty much keep my phone in
silent and mute all the time so it's not
that often that I pop out of that but
what I will definitely be getting use
out of is customizing this action button
to do set actions there's a really cool
little interface you can see here that I
got a demo of on the show floor you can
go through the settings and choose
whatever you want this action to do you
can set it up to open up your camera you
can do Focus mode there's all sorts of
different settings and it's pretty
incredible and this is going to be super
useful for me because I'm setting this
up to activate my camera so as soon as I
press that button my camera will be open
and ready to film whatever it is that
I'm trying to shoot the new A7 Pro chip
is a big upgrade it has a six core GPU
which is going to be amazing for
performance across the board but
especially for gaming I got a chance to
play as some Diablo Immortal and I don't
know if you guys remember but I was
super obsessed with this game when it
first came out during the product demo
it was super smooth the 15 Pro now uses
Hardware accelerated rate tracing which
makes graphics lighting effects look so
realistic so the 15 Pro and the pro Max
now have a completely redesigned camera
system it has a new 48 megap Main camera
as the star of the show you can now
choose between three different focal
lengths in the main camera and this is a
game changer for pro photographers
you'll now have seven different lenses
to choose from there's the ultrawide 13
mm and macro 24 mm 28 35 on the main
lenses 2x telephoto at 48 mm and with
the pro Max the allnew 5x telephoto lens
LS at 120 mm something else I thought
that was interesting is all along we
were calling this technology the
Periscope camera but Apple did not call
it that they called it tetr prism which
to be honest with you actually sounds a
lot cooler it basically uses a series of
angled mirrors to reflect the image four
times allowing the light to travel a
longer distance in a smaller space and
that's how we're getting the 120 mm
focal length and keep in mind that this
camera still supports sensor shift
Optical image stabilization and with
this new 48 megap camera there are big
improvements to night mode and portraits
on the iPhone 15 Pro as well now video
on the iPhone for me is it's like my
first child it is something that I love
it is something that I use so much of
and if all of my other cameras went away
and I only had an iPhone I think I would
be okay I definitely would miss having
all of my studio cameras but I could
survive prores video now has log en
coding which will allow us to have
better dynamic range and flexibility for
editing and post you can also record
externally now which will be so amazing
for pro video workflows and probably the
biggest new feature for video is the
ability to shoot spatial videos which
you can capture with the iPhone 15 Pro
and then view them with the Vision Pro
to do this you're going to be using
these two cameras right here and when
you turn the phone sideways you're
shooting video with both cameras at the
same time and by capturing depth data
this will create videos that will feel
like you're actually reliving the moment
so essentially without saying it you're
shooting a stereoscopic image using
those two cameras at the same time I've
shot a few 3D videos in my day some are
here on my YouTube channel so it's going
to be really cool to be giving this
power to just everyday consumers
something like this is gamechanging and
then with the introduction of Vision Pro
oh man spatial Computing spatial video
shooting for the win now with USBC comes
power and responsibility or something is
it I'm not sure how the saying goes with
great what how's that saying go with
great power comes great responsibility
now the responsibility is we need all of
our products that are still lightning to
be USBC and that first step is the
airpods pro to USBC now this isn't
airpods Pro 3 this is kind of like a 2.5
version because there are some
differences yes of course the big one is
the fact that it is USBC and we will be
able to charge with our iPhone actually
which is kind of exciting now in the
future with our Vision Pro using the
USBC airpods Pro 2 you'll be able to get
lossless audio which is going to make
that entire spatial Computing just even
that more realistic I also got a chance
to chat with two apple Executives Lisa
and John about the environmental impacts
that apple is planning to have in the
future it was really impressive to hear
how they're putting the environment but
also products first making sure that yes
they are environmentally friendly but
we're not losing quality I had so much
fun with the events if you guys want to
watch more videos you can check them all
out here and of course check out my full
Channel youtube.com/ Justine and
hopefully you can find some more fun
content that you want to watch